hi my name is al cheetah professor home
and see at located in the singapore i
had measure to facilitate a section of
young global leaders of the world come
form a group of sanitation projects
promising individuals by the economic we
basically try to cover the whole range
of topics of the floor as we get under
the leadership of these four young
leaders they thought they had introduced
on topic then have a discussion the
number all muttering much more simple
and they will have self it was
interesting how much month gets very
sharp you Hotel paints young because
Adam took the more senior there was no
clear consensus on the various topics
but if I may sunrises reflect the
palette Edwards great deal of care from
with our future with obviously the arms
twentieth young leaders there was a
great deal of concern of working
together private sector and the
government sector and do more than
thinking about next quarter or the next
either to build election but to think in
the periods of potatoes lately fifty
years especially over the came to clean
environment we came to professional
education all the way of government
overall my impression and being a
representative of the older generation
got business new generation much hope
the world should be very optimistic to
find good solutions which solved
problems which are not problems of
individual countries but global net
thank you